welcome everybody to part 2 of our
google cloud tutorial miniseries in this
video what we're doing is covering the
first API but also just kind of how to
set up any of the api's that you're
going to use because the first time you
go through this you've got to deal with
some sort of API validation key and
stuff like that so also you have to
install the actual Google cloud stuff to
work on the server so anyway the first
one that we're going to work with is the
actual vision API so this is something
you can feed an image to and it can and
the API will basically give you
information on this image what's in the
image what is the image about I can even
give you some metadata on that image so
if it sees something that it recognizes
so if you fed it an image of like the
Eiffel Tower or something like that the
metadata might include the Wikipedia
page for the Eiffel Tower anyway let's
go ahead and get started so you should
be on a fresh server we did install a CH
top so we could pop on in there and look
at H top if we wanted ctrl C to get out
of that and so we should be in our kind
of typical home directory so and it's
not just CD facility here and then that
way we're basically back at just well
this puts us in the root directory so
now what I want us to go ahead and do is
we're going to make Durer we'll call
this G cloud stuff and then let's change
directory CD G cloud stuff and what I'm
going to do here is first let's go ahead
and make sure we've got pips so you
should have it but just in case sudo
apt-get install actually I'm not sure if
these servers will come with pip or not
anyway should I have to get install a
Python - pip nope it doesn't look like
we had it already so cool let's grab it
another thing we probably should have
done is an update and upgrade but you
can do that on your own time I think
we'll get away with not doing
even piss taking a while once we get tip
we're going to install Google - cloud
you can alternatively do Google - cloud
- vision that's the only one you want
since I'm going to be doing a series on
Google cloud I'm going to do sudo pip
install Google - clap but if you just
wanted vision you can type - vision but
I want the whole thing so I'm going to
install the full everything so just as
you can see everything is getting
installed here once we've done that
there's one more thing that we really
need to do and that is the API T for
dealing with the api's so while this is
running head back over to Google cloud
here and let's click on the wool
hamburger thing go to API manager and
then come on down to credentials and
once you're in the credentials what
we're going to do is create credentials
we'll do a service account key and let's
choose a new service account and I'm
going to call this API - it's all be
like that role project and let's just
give it owner which just gives us full
access to everything so I'm going to
give it owner you can give it really
specific access so if you had you know
if this was your business and then you
could give specific keys to certain of
your employees or something like that
but for now I'm the owner so I get full
access
we do want JSON so we'll hit create and
this will give us a file that's going to
download a file downloaded go ahead and
just kind of save it and put it
somewhere so save to my computer I'm
going to move this over here and what
we're going to do now is well I'm just
going to leave it there but we can open
it up and this is the file so it just
has some information in here I wouldn't
show this to people normally but this
server will be deleted soon enough
anyway
so by the time you see it this won't
matter anyway but anyways that's what's
in it it uses something we can copy and
paste so we've got that let's go back to
our server now
and what I'm going to do is what's weird
we just installed it and it watches
update okay let's get we can upgrade it
that's fine - install - - that's pretty
yep and now we want to do is add this
API key so I'm going to go ahead and
just a nano API T dot JSON that's an
empty file so I'm going to now take that
file that we just downloaded from Google
copy come over here
paste ctrl X - safe yes enter whatever
you can feel free to use a different
editor if you like I know someone's
going to like why did you use man oh
okay so I like to use silly editors now
once we've done that so the next thing
that we can do is so for example like if
you if you go to Google basically what
they tell you to do is okay export and
then Google underscore application
underscore Prudential equals and then
you give the path those credentials this
is going to run off the screen so let me
make sure this is all shown there we go
equals and then the path to what we just
made so g-cloud stuff you can hit tab to
autocomplete API key JSON so we could do
that and hit enter maybe not a valid
identifier export what did I do wrong
let's see X for Google application
credentials maybe no space I'm not
positive Y that fails okay I guess it's
a space that's interesting okay let the
problem with this is if you restart your
server or whatever it's not going to
work so what we're going to go ahead and
do is let's do nano till the flash
period on file and then just go to the
very bottom of this profile and then
actually what we want to do is copy that
line so let's go ahead and copy this
line here you can right click to copy
there it is I don't
want that there and then now let's go
ahead and nano into the profile again
and then right click to paste now let's
fix this little space here and then
control X yes good and then to update
that will be source bash RC and now
we'll be working off that either way it
should have worked as we exported it
initially but basically this is like
adding something to your path so now
when when we use the Google cloud cut
Python API it knows okay here's where we
can find the API key all right so now
we've done that let's go ahead I'm going
to make the vision the X for example I'm
gonna CD into this gem DX great now I'm
going to go ahead and nano vision X up
PI and this will be a new python file
and what we're going to go ahead and do
is first I'm going to import i/o I'm
going to go from Google's cloud import
vision and then we can specify vision
clients on this tech vision client
Eagles vision Docs clients and now we
need an image so what I'm going to go
ahead and do is come over here and I'm
just going to search for we go Rossum
great let's go to his Wikipedia page
great picture let's copy that image
address and then we'll come back over
here and in fact we need to kind of let
me just save this here so yes okay so
we're back over here control X days yes
I'm going to do with W get that image
awesome
so that image name is here LS to list up
the directory I'm going to copy that
image and then now back vanna visionary
nan-oh and now we're going to specify
the filename so we're going take file
name D equals right-click boom I'm sure
it's not running over my face and now
we've got the file so now we want to
load this image into memory so we're
just a wisp IO dot open file name RB as
image file what do we want to do there
is a content equals image underscore
file dot read we're going to say image
equals vision underscore client dot
image and then content equals contents
[Music]
and then we can get something simple
like the label there's more things that
we can do as vision we're going to
continue but for now I just want to do
something really simple and basic
because this one is going to serve both
as an intro to division API but also
just how to use any of the API is
because the process is pretty similar
labels equals image dot detect
underscore labels so they'll just tell
us what Google happens to see in this
image so we're just going to print out
in fact let's get irate through labels
so let's say for labels in labels we can
print print label dot description and
let's just do that and then I'm going to
give you some advice on using this API
so yes
enter and let's go ahead and I think we
might have to use pseudo for this but
let's just try to run it without pseudo
oh we haven't enabled the API okay so
the okay the whole point of this
tutorial so yeah we so we got this
permission denied so we got the API key
but we haven't enabled division API in
our actual platform so the easiest thing
to do there is some way to get there
probably here maybe I don't know I don't
know how to get there for real but you
can just search like vision boom google
cloud vision API no problem you get here
enable the API okay
now we'll come back over it did say wait
a few minutes after you you enable the
API let's go ahead and try it
post that in just sacrifice a few
minutes for everybody boom done so
actually that was very quick okay so
what does it see any image it sees hair
face person facial hair nose chin hair
style beard and senior citizen sorry
greena okay so um so this are like a
really quick example there's more stuff
I'm definitely going to show you but the
one thing I do want to show you that I
think is kind of part of all the api's
is I think the document usually Google
is really good about documentation but
there's a lot of the examples that don't
have Python examples yet and then the
documentation is met and the code is
kind of a challenge to crawl through so
for example when you have like the
labels and labels and actually even
labels like so for example I'm trying to
think how I want to do this what I
probably could do is I think we'll do
this let me just copy this exit no let's
run Python and I think I can do this
let's see if this code if we get away
with this great so so I'm just running
this in regular Python so if we do
something like this like dirt this will
tell you all the kind of attributes of
something right so for example we could
say dur labels and this just tells us
kind of like what does all the
attributes and things and methods that
we can do we've got a pend count count
okay so clearly this is something that's
been iterable just by looking at this
but then what what we can do is like for
label endure or rather let's see let me
just completely real quick yeah so let's
do der label as we can see each of the
labels like because basically this is
storing the last label that was iterated
through kind of a thing with Python so
what we have or all the attributes of a
label that we could possibly access so
these ones you anything with the
underscores you probably leave alone
unless you really know what you're doing
but you've got interesting do this score
anymore yes I do okay so bounds
description from an API repper I'm not
sure what that even does I don't know if
this one is either locale locations mid
I don't know and score but like we use
dot description to get what is the
actual thing right that gave us the hair
the face beard person and all that kind
of stuff but there's some other
attributes too like locations
unfortunately I don't think I've ever
seen locations work so for example for
label in labels print label dot or
locations
let's give able dot locations label dot
locale I don't think that one either has
any information yeah so locale I'm not
really sure locale what that would
normally give you so clearly it looks
like it's going to give you a you know
text data of some kind but anyway I was
really hoping locations would work but I
actually haven't found an image that
locations works on at all so it'd be
nice if you could show the vision API a
picture of a bunch of cars and it would
see yes it says cars and then here are
all the X&Y coordinates for those cars
or even better like a box that would be
awesome
to give you like the box coordinates
like the top left in the bottom right
corner that'd be really neat
but that doesn't think may be the case
and like I said nursing locations work
clearly looks like it's probably going
to be some X&Y data or even a box data
but it's just not there so and I'm sorry
guys I've never seen it actually doing
it but you do get it at least an
explanation of what
image you're looking at which is
actually pretty impressive and then like
I said some of the stuff gets even more
interesting because it especially if you
if you show it things that should have
metadata and it actually finds committed
okay so that's a really quick example of
the vision API and then also just using
API is in general don't forget to enable
the API I always forget but at least now
you know what it's going to look like
when you do forget it's going to be like
this permission denied basically go and
enable the API also the key we won't
ever have to do that again so now that
it knows where the key is we don't have
to generate a key every time we want to
use a different API but you do have to
enable that API all right so if you have
questions comments concerns whatever
feel free to leave them below otherwise
I will see you in the next video where
we're going to be doing a little bit
more with the vision API because it's a
cool API and you can do some things with
it but other than that see you next time